hey welcome to D LM model lifestyle I'm
Daniel
now I made a video about ten things guys
do that girls hate so I thought it's
just fair to make another video on ten
things that women do girls do that guys
just the hate so let's get into the
video mistakes mistakes make you
stronger
now if this is your first time here on
my channel subscribe and click the
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos now I know that I
might get a lot of hate with this video
but it is just a fun video and he's not
personal and so if you're open to it you
might just learn something so let's
start with number one
[Music]
when a girl talks too much full the time
and I don't mean just about herself but
about everything men don't like that so
just give them a chance to speak as well
I get it you have a lot on your mind and
so much to share right but just give a
guy the chance to share his life with
you as well and please stop talking when
you're watching a movie together with a
guy
baby voice guys hate it when a girl
talks in a baby voice there's a huge
difference between baby voice and
sounding very cute we like it when you
sound cute baby voice not so much
[Music]
dropping those hints guys don't like it
when women just drop those kind of hints
you know and don't say exactly what you
mean and let's be honest most of the
time we don't really catch those hints
anyway because we just think differently
now if you still think that dropping
hints will work rather just save
yourself some time and just be direct
and say exactly what you feel and what
you think we like that but do it in a
kind way
being too clingy for example texting a
message every time when you're bored is
actually telling us hey I'm very clingy
and I need attention right now of course
it is good to reach out to us every now
and then but not a hundred times a day
you know sometimes a guy he just needs
to do his own thing and when he's doing
his own thing just let him be
taking off a guy's hat or messing up his
hair no men do not think that you are
cute and playful when you do it so he
just spent the whole morning trying to
style his hair making it look good for
you and now you just come and mess it up
no just no bragging on how little your
exercise and how bad your diet is why
would men like that especially since men
like women that takes good care of
themselves because it just shows us that
you respect yourself enough to really
take good care of yourself
when a woman complains all the time if
the girl complains all the time you just
kind of sucked the life out of a man and
it's like you know when a the tap is
leaking that annoying sound with the
water that keeps on dripping that is how
it sounds like and feels like if a woman
complains all the time the so annoying
when a girl compares her relationship
with a guy to their friends relationship
I don't need to say anything about this
one do I
when girls blame all the men in the
whole world for something her man did to
her now I know I really know there's a
lot of bad guys out there and it is hard
to move on from a really bad
relationship but just remember all the
men out there are not the same just like
all the girls are not the same everybody
is unique when girls wear too much
makeup men do not find it attractive
we actually hate it so don't hide
yourself under a painting have the
confidence to show the real beauty less
is more
guys hated it if girls tell them what to
do all the time it's okay to do it every
now and then that that's fine but they
do it all the time even if you think you
know better just give him a few options
for example ask him hey do you think
it's better to do a or do you think it
is a little bit better to do B or C so
then he will feel a lot better about it
and feel like oh she really wants to
hear my opinion as well now just some
last advice relationships are supposed
to be fun because love is the greatest
thing that you can experience but today
sadly most people out there try to find
the right person first instead of being
the right person but you see the problem
is we soon realized that nobody out
there is perfect and we give up on a
relationship too soon in such a way that
the divorce rate just skyrocketed this
last few years in the u.s. it's 53
percent in countries like Spain Portugal
Czech Republic and Hungary over 60% and
Belgium with the highest of 70% I've
been married for eight years with an
amazing wife and we know that
relationships need a lot of work to make
it one of the greatest experiences in
your life now if you like reading I'll
add a few good relationship books for
your individual description down below
that you can check out that's it guys
thank you so much for watching if you
liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]